everyone did an oopsie
[Music]
my name is glue
area border and you're watching the most
respectable news site outlet of all time
that is not our personal bias that is
just straight-up facts now some news for
a lesser media outlet bus feed everyone
pathetic BuzzFeed prints a one-off
magazine wow that's incredible
wow how innovative going back to print
what a great idea and put Momo on the
cover this is phenomenal work by speed
good job by speed you really did you're
really outdone yourself this time by
speed can I sound a little bit more
condescending so this was on my Twitter
newsfeed for some reason Twitter decided
hey you want to know about this
BuzzFeed everyone it's a and I loved all
the responses to this basically no one
cares
good call moving to brain booming
industry so you're telling me the
creative director said when history
looks back at bus feeds number one issue
we want the iconic mama to be undercover
well well well too bad there won't be
any history for BuzzFeed I know this is
so sad last month it was reported that
as many as 2,100 people have lost their
media jobs in the past two weeks
BuzzFeed having a cut of 15% of its
staff this is so sad okay I'm not giving
my opinion but I'm literally shaking and
crying right now
BuzzFeed who hire such amazing people
like Joe Bernstein oh god no no I lied
not Vice to Vice laying off ten
percenter they were of course vice at
are such incredible journalism I mean
this is a huge blow for journalism how
are we possibly going to survive now
obviously people losing their job is not
to be celebrated but but kind of hard to
feel bad for companies that have run
these smear campaigns and not just
against me but other people as well are
you supported a keep thinking they can
do this kind of stuff without getting
away with it obviously there are many
factors involved but I find it ironic
and funny how a BuzzFeed two years ago
after the Wall Street Journal scandal
posted about my downfall writing his
downfall fields and the capitalist it
feels non conformist it makes us feel
all the things we love to feel when
trying to prove we're better than that
well well well what a downfall indeed
have fun BuzzFeed I'll be laughing all
the way
next news next news comes from Captain
Marvel that's right y'all know I would
talk about this the reason why I haven't
done a few news in a while this I
haven't been too invested in what's
happening and it's been kind of nice to
be honest but this is one of those news
that you just can't you can't escape
it's been literally everywhere
recommended in all the feeds Rotten
Tomatoes explains why it removed
thousands of audience reviews on Captain
Marvel's opening day well I don't even
have to research this Disney paid that
that is not facts that is just pure
speculation but it also most importantly
is my opinion basically if you don't
know what happened here the Captain
Marvel audience score review on Ron
tomatoes was at 33% and then a lot of
review stirs disappeared and got deleted
some people were estimating over 50,000
and now it's sitting at 55% like ratio
now whoever still enjoys Marvel films
you know that's that's up to you but a
lot of people define this as trolls you
know this is trolls and therefore we
have every right to remove their review
you're a troll then your opinion doesn't
count basically is trolls that's a good
excuse to remove freedom of speech if
you're a troll then you're not allowed
to voice your opinion this annoys me so
much because it reminds me of the
goddamn Amy Schumer thing I don't know
if you remember her Netflix special
which was one of the worst thing I've
ever watched and Ikey I watch that with
an open mind five percent liked this
film according to Google users after the
bad reviews came out on Netflix from
name is Schumer special they removed the
five star rating system which now makes
it impossible to find something that you
actually like on Nathalie
I've just given up trying to find stuff
from their run to Maine said that it was
a bug a bug that removed ten thousands
of audience review okay Ron tomatoes
sure sure are we expected to believe
this now you might ask yourself why why
was it getting bad reviews at the
beginning well some people obviously
liked the film some people described it
as bland and not that interesting and I
mean considering how many Marvel films
they've done at this point it's probably
kind of hard to innovate personally I
think a lot of people dislike this film
because of the main Cara main actress
brie Larson who is probably one of the
most unlikable lead female characters
I've seen in a long time I mean just and
one more question um what does it mean
to be a woman in film it means it's
really hard and if you're a woman of
color then it's really really hard god
everyone just wants to be a victim don't
think imagine being the lead lead of a
multimillion what is it like 500 million
was the pledge for this baby doesn't
matter and then say it's really hard to
imagine being attractive being paid
millions and then going it's so hard
like Jesus Christ imagine being the
figure of a female strong character and
going it's really hard Jesus Christ
now what's ironic about this whole
situation but review skins removed is
that Libra and Larson hundra herself in
the past expressed that she doesn't like
the way the system of reviews is done
because a movie that she liked what was
it a tangle in time or something was
called a wrinkle in time got bad reviews
her response to that was basically well
it wasn't made for you 67% of white men
are making these reviews that's why it
got bad reviews because it wasn't made
for white man okay released findings
that 67% of the top critics reviewing
the 100 highest-grossing movies in 2017
were white males less than a quarter
were white women and less than 10% were
unrepresented men
only 2.5 percent of those top critics or
women of color it's important to note
the fact here that brie Larson doesn't
hate white man and I'm also saying I
don't hate white dudes I'm just saying
I'm not supposed to give my opinion but
I'm just saying am I saying that I hate
white dudes no I'm not let me try and
unwrinkled this she hates white students
or I and for the third time I don't hate
white dudes now whether you agree with
her or not
I think her politics is what muddled
people's opinion about her at least and
I think that's fair you know not
everyone wants to politics and
everything and I see it is getting kind
of knowing at this point I think what
annoys me the most out of all this is
it's the straw Manning of if you didn't
like this film then that means you're a
troll or that you don't like seeing
strong female characters or yada yada
yada it's the same thing every time I
stumbled upon this footage for example
there are people who get very bent out
of shape about the fact that she's a
woman and that buries a woman and wants
to see women moving into an equal place
inhumanity to men sad it must be sad to
me that kind of dinosaur wandering
toward the Tar Pits ah yes
that's why Aleta battling Joe was
getting so much hate as well that's what
people are been out of shape over that
movie getting released or Wonder Woman
or literally hundreds of female main
character films no one cares no one is
making this argument that people don't
want equality or seeing strong female
character
whatever it was he said and wants to see
women moving into an equal place in
humanity to men or that women can move
in tune equal plays out a man no one is
saying that no one maybe like a very
small percentage but of course anyone
that dislike this film you don't want to
see wither then you just don't want to
see women moving in to the same place
you know what people don't realize how
hard it is being a female news anchor
but you don't see me complaining about
it now 400 times more important news dog
showed up for story time at library but
nobody came to read to him no
unfortunately nobody signed up to read
to sting at the White Bear Lake library
I'm shaking and crying what Felix this
news was posted a year ago why are you
talking about this now it is still
relevant
goddamnit Forbes attacks PD PI that's
right they wrote this article saying
it's time to unsubscribe from PD P
versus T series okay alright they're
basically saying both channels have been
irresponsible prioritizing the attention
growth of their channels instead of
helping to create a wholesome YouTube
community Oh Forbes just care about
creating a wholesome YouTube community
support the creator's the community is
what God involved with this I didn't
even start this whole thing it's the
community that keeps it alive and
they've done so many incredible things
that I'm so proud of and the reason why
they're bringing this up is because a
few days ago it came up that someone
defaced a world war 2 memorial by AB
writing subscribe to PewDiePie this has
been covered in so many different places
and obviously it is desire it's
disgusting you know I don't think I've
done anything to condone this sort of
behavior but of course a Forbes right
right after that I've said a good meme
for a good cause
and I sort of implying that they even
wrote it straight out the Creator hasn't
made any effort to temper the extremes
of his fanbase what am I gonna do like
first of all that's just not true I
already said in many times that don't do
anything legal because I would obviously
look bad on me but doing this sort of
hack print acts
people doing protests people being
holding up signs all these things are
just amazing and really fun to follow
and I think it's really cool no I don't
think I've done anything to to condone
this sort of behavior
obviously it's disgusting obviously I
don't condone it whatsoever
I don't know why anyone got in their
mind to do this it's just stupid most
likely it's just a kid it looks like
they just grabbed a stone to scribe it
in and the mix of large and small
letters kind of signifies it as well it
looks like it's many different kids it
looks like you could probably remove
that pretty easily at least which I'm
really glad because I would hate for
that to to be there if anyone knows if
it has been removed please let me know
because it's just terrible
honestly don't do this I don't know it's
like I'm expected to say don't do this
obviously don't do this do I shouldn't
have to say it even
but of course Forbes has to go out of
their way to it that's it for Pio news
hope you guys enjoyed this episode smash
like check out the merch and I see you
guys next time
Gloria Borger out Booga Booga Booga
Booga Booga bye tuber simulator it's now
so relevant that it's got a brand new
mini game cranium drop the crane and get
fresh items only available in the
washing machine like game and you say
there's more of course there is new
knowledge perks new quests and new picks
links and legs guys legs